can you be too happy do you think I mean
we all know the person that just kind of
lives in the clouds that may be smiling
all the time but really isn't on the
ball or basically isn't on planet Earth
Lex Friedman sorry I had something stuck
in my well he's not really not that I
wanted to talk about him but he and I
argue he engages in full happiness right
he's always I love you you love me let's
hug what was his what was his tweet a
couple weeks ago that everybody went
crazy on I think you really nailed him
on wasn't there something uh not too
long ago whether you call yourself male
or female I care about what your
character is or something like that and
and that pissed me off now again people
think when I go after someone I'm trying
to be me I'm not and that's because
there's a part of me that's a dogged
Defender Of Truth and actually I talk
about this in the book that existential
authenticity is a sure Pathway to
happiness right I present myself to the
world as though I'm 18 feet tall because
I'm always authentic I really know my
qualities I know my faults I don't
modulate anything and so there are no
fisters in my personhood and that's why
I then can feel comfortable in any
setting because I've got nothing to I
don't have to retain lies It For Better
or Worse here I am and and what I was
pissed with legs is that is you know I
didn't know who Lex was frankly but then
people said oh you should go on his show
what are some of the other tricks that
that people can use if they're really in
a funk you know when somebody when
you're in those moments in life that
you're just tripped up family problems
money problems you're doing the job you
don't want to do like the whole thing
seems like it's off do you have some
tricks that can kind of just get someone
going because it seems like that first
step is often the biggest hurdle I
actually so I have a whole chapter so it
speaks partially to the question you're
asking uh I have a whole chapter on sort
of how can you minimize regret in life
because regret in a sense is that
existential you know voice that keeps
coming in your head that makes you think
what if what if I've done this what I've
what if I've done that right and so many
of us think that opportunities for
happiness have passed us by we're too
old to be let's say I know that you love
the NBA well that is true that is
objectively true it would be silly for
you or I to think about being NBA Stars
although you have seen some of my
three-point shots so maybe I can still
make it plus we have had some good back
and forth that's right that's right but
no but seriously uh there are many cases
where that sense of I can't get out of
this funk is is sort of a deterministic
doom whereas in reality you've placed
this restriction in your so let me give
it to again two examples
example one uh this is from in the book
there's a gentleman who left a pre-nazi
Germany he was a Jewish guy left and
came to Canada had always wanted to
study and you know get a university
education but life circumstances didn't
allow him to he comes to Canada as a
young kid uh goes to work has a
successful career retires in his 60s
hit now he's in his 60s right I mean
average undergrad is 20 19. he says you
know what I'm now I'm of good mind I
have time why don't I sign up he
actually went to the university that I
work with uh at and he said why don't I
sign up and take some undergraduate
courses lo and behold a few years later
he finishes his undergrad then he says
hey I'm still young I'm now in my 70s
why don't I pursue my Master's Degree
finishes it and then in his 80s starts
his PhD and I remember this was in 1996
it was very early in my academic career
the the University newspaper had the
title something like finally a doctor at
91 and so he finishes his PhD and within
a year he passes away so he could have
easily said uh you know I missed my
opportunity to study well no you had an
opportunity to do it and you did it
second example I just had this guy last
year on my show
this is a physician who got I think his
medical degree at University of Vienna
in 1955 then while he was training to be
a hematologist as a specialist picked up
a PhD in 1967. you weren't born yet I
was two years old two and a half years
old
but he had always wanted to be a
physicist his real love was physics but
his family had told him Jewish guy you
have to do something practical become a
physician blah blah blah and he did it
at the age of 89 he completed a second
PhD in physics at Brown University so
why am I telling you these again these
stories because oftentimes we're in a
funk because we place these arbitrary
illusory barriers in our minds yes we
can't be future NBA stars we're too old
for that we can't be ballerinas we're
not going to be Maestro violinists but
for many other things that would make us
happy it's only our inner voice that's
stopping us from doing so get off the
couch and go do it
can you be too happy do you think I mean
we all know the person that just kind of
lives in the clouds that may be smiling
all the time but really isn't on the
ball or basically isn't on planet Earth
Lex Friedman sorry I had something stuck
in my well he's not really not that I
wanted to talk about him but he and I
argue he engages in full happiness right
he's always I love you you love me let's
hug I think what was his what was his
tweet a couple weeks ago that everybody
went crazy on I think you really nailed
him on wasn't there something uh too
long ago whether you call yourself male
or female I care about what your
character is or something like that and
and that pissed me off now again people
think when I go after someone I'm trying
to be me I'm not and that's because
there's a part of me that's a dogged
Defender Of Truth and actually I talk
about this in the book that existential
authenticity is a sure Pathway to
happiness right I present myself to the
world as though I'm 18 feet tall because
I'm always authentic I really know my
qualities I know my faults I don't
modulate anything and so there are no
fisters in my personhood and that's why
I then can feel comfortable in any
setting because I've got nothing to I
don't have to retain lies It For Better
or Worse here I am and and what I was
pissed with legs is that is you know I
didn't know who Lex was frankly but then
people said oh you should go on his show
that's how I started getting to know him
and then I would see all this inane
that he would consistently post
and it just pissed me off so in his case
I don't know if he's being real or not
he he has gone into the extra happiness
because not everything in life is about
hugging and happiness right I mean uh
that's a false narrative and that's why
I tried to go after him and now to his
lack of credit he always says oh I
always am willing to learn from anyone
and speak to anyone first thing he does
is he blocks me what a schmuck foreign
so you can be happy and still think
someone's a schmuck that's good that
should definitely exactly right and by
the way to to that point people often
say to me oh when they meet me oh you
seem so much nicer and friendlier than
on social media no because this is
called situational specificity right if
you attack me in a in an alley I might
be violent because you're trying to mug
me that's not because I'm
dispositionally violent it's because I
act differently when I'm tucking my
children to bed and when I'm being
mugged in an alley so when I am being
mugged by on social media I act
in a spicier manner not because I'm not
happy or I'm mean or I'm it's because
different strategies require different
approaches I mean or different contexts
so you're a little happier when you're
basically putting your kids to sleep
than you are when you're being mugged I
just want to make sure I got that one
clean that is that is a correct
statement indeed what about uh the
things that people at least give get the
temporary happiness on whether it might
be the uh the booze or the extra
Indulgence in food or whatever they
might be smoking or the other stuff
completely fleeting so I talk about in
the book as a as someone who studies
consumer psychology right so I wanted to
link it to some of my own interests so
there's been now several studies that
I've looked at whether spending money on
material possessions so that speaks to
kind of your point right should I get
the next product bag or the really cool
Gucci or the Maserati whether spend what
brings you greater long-term happiness
the spending on money on material
possessions or on experiences and
overwhelmingly repeatedly the research
shows that for long-term enduring
happiness living a life of Rich
experiences is going to bring you a lot
more bang for the buck than if you spend
it on Ferrari and I know this from
personal experience because one of my
brothers who until recently lived in
Southern California and was very very
wealthy during the.com era he had not
one not two but three Ferraris he had an
Aston Martin lagunda he had also he was
a collector of conspicuous consumption
Goods uh I hate to say it and I don't
say this with any Glee uh I don't think
today he's happy right whereas I never
drove a Ferrari I never had access to a
Ferrari but later today my children are
going to come and are going to say oh
how was your chat with Dave Rubin that
moment right there is probably makes me
wealthier than all of his Ferraris put
together
honest and thoughtful conversations
about Academia check out our Academia
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell